jason haag tigana à son âge qui vient
d'arriver de fou ça paraît dingue joli
mais on vient d'apprendre que les hommes
sont incapable d'écouter leurs femmes
plus de six minutes à cod vu d'aussi
leur mort ne sont pas capables d'écouter
leurs neuf plus de six minutes
sachez que je ne fais pas partie de ceux
là c'est moi c'est plus de deux minutes
[Rires]
olalala le test a été réalisé sur deux
mille hommes à qui on a demandé
d'écouter attentivement leurs femmes
puis de répondre à un questionnaire sur
ce que leur femme leur a raconté
c'est pas bon pas et bien après six
minutes l'homme ne retient plus rien ça
veut dire au bout de six minutes frère
il a décroché mais ça mais en plus ils
en interrompt le garde ça veut dire en
vrai et ça faisait ça veut dire ces deux
minutes d'alex concentré doux nom au
bout de six minutes ça y est parti et il
est encore les hommes ne retienne
quasiment rien quand leurs femmes
parlent devant la télévision ou quand
ils jouent avec leur smartphone alors là
c'est vrai on est souvent comme ça là et
là elle me faisait pas mais tu dis mais
qu'est ce tu y raconte par tranches en
fait exactement est ce que des hommes
ils sont incapables de faire deux choses
en même temps les familles vous pouvez
quand même hâte sur votre smartphone
vous répondez très bien comment ça se
fait sabena vous êtes 7 supérieur seces
on travaille on fait travailler tous les
hémisphères notre cerveau en même temps
c'est que je croisais passerelle après
nous donnant un doublement des rebelles
lui déjà et je ne fus pas sur des demis
faire
[Applaudissements]
plus la personne tapas d'hémisphère de
faire à mon avis comme papa d'amy toi
mais je peux lui alors qui est concernée
qui sent que ces savons qu un stadier
c'est vrai que les femmes elles ont un
don pour faire des efforts qu'ils durent
très longtemps et que peu de détails
ah oui c'est chiant en fait au bout d'un
moment c'est vrai castaldi on voit
pourquoi les femmes vous quitter c'est
vrai que c'était juste pour jouer
c'était pour autre chose mais sa rage ou
isabelle minutes
est-ce que je qu'après 40 ans tu le
passes des préliminaires je vais à
l'essentiel et ben même comme ça
systématiquement je dis qu'est ce que je
viens de dire
lui je peux le comprendre il ya trois
minutes grâce à lui que vous regardez
c'est surtout aujourd'hui remo
retirée
vraiment
elle manquait sa balle est à bord du
fils de dents moi je suis assez mal
aussi mais en voiture en voiture elle
parle et je suis déjà en train de
chanter la chanson à me dit tu chantes
tu en a rien à [ __ ] de ce que je pense
pas alors tu en penses quoi
quand elle te demande alors tu en penses
quoi te donne moi ton avis t'as même pas
écouter ce cas-là 10 ans bons mais
j'étais alors là c'est la gueule pendant
10 à 20 des morts maxime guide ça dépend
du moment de la journée
pour le soir évidemment je suis obligé
de tout couper aurélia d'avoir une
copine à revel avec nous s'il était un
canard boiteux
parce qu'il n'a commencé tard le soir
quand je rentre week-end mais celui qui
est le schéma où je te donne ma chance
mais je vis à l'inversé a tendance à
laisser partir reprises toujours
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
donc vous avez dit quand je rentre chez
moi
ouais quand je rentre chez moi je suis
obligé de poser tous mes instruments
voulait qu'elle rend le portable est
éteint la télévision pour avoir une
attention total mais alors donc on va
reprendre s'il vous plaît à new day de
leurs maux de la mondaine
tu peux lui poser la question que tout
le monde attend 10 mois à gagny
n'essaierai pas de nous la faire à
l'envers
skinny qui tu attends chez toi quand tu
rentres vrai pas falloir tu fais ton sac
évite les nuits je veux tout savoir sur
et nom prénom profession ce qu'elle
mange le soir sa taille en ballerines
gagner on va tout savoir
ça les amis je vais je vous décevoir il
un collectionneur d'histoire j'ai une
grande expérience et mon anecdote était
évidemment au passé en fonction de leur
expérience la grande expérience de la
vie tu mangani on avait tous raison en
fait on s'est réuni pour rien voilà donc
je rappelle le solage chez vous nous
rejoignez c'est un sondage qui est fou
donc un homme ne peut pas écouter sa
meuf pendant plus de six minutes voilà
par sa thématique pas pourquoi je vais
vous donner qui ont donné le top des
sujets qui n'intéressent pas les hommes
quand leurs femmes la palme du 8 au
premier bout alors vous venez d'abord
réagir surdimensionné c'est une femme
vous dit cyril tu es beau tu es riche et
puissant je t'aime j'ai merveilleux tu
va décrocher
j'ai dit non plus que les gens aient de
bonnes amies donnant pas nulles et non
mais pas du tout mais c'est parce qu'il
faut savoir vous intéresser il faut
savoir vous titiller les halons si on
commence à se plaindre acquis et des
reproches pour la voir mais c'est vrai
mais c'est pas moi le sondage est donc
mettez dedans c'est en sont extraits
très sérieux du point.fr moi j'ai rien à
voir là dedans on dirait qu'ils ont
interrogé que moi ils ont interrogé deux
hommes verts et moi joe pareil les mains
dans mes bras droit je vais vous écoutez
moi je peux coup d'une femme pendant des
années des soirées parlé donnant autant
le dernière expo de mouthe la vie tchô
clarity beaucoup habitent donc je
connaissais pas un sculpteur est ce que
tu as trois boîtes de l'art moderne d'où
de quelle ville tenait ce culte sur des
babouches
oui calais moi je pense que c'est le
point de mes fesses parce que je pense
qu'on a vraiment tous la même chose
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
société est un cador venait avec le
temps elle dit une fois j'ai quoi de si
dur que ça n'a rien à voir donc alors
vous êtes dur après vous parler du jeu
ou mal dites c'est pas le point c'est le
point de vos fesses d'accord parce que
je pense qu'on a tous les mêmes
capacités à retenir et à écouter c'est
un peu moins que les hommes font
semblant de ne pas retenir être pas
écouté d'accord je vous ai fait quelques
piges fnpd jean-michel moi j'étais à 6
minutes sans aucun problème et gok
mérite je suis sorti qu'une tunisienne
pendant deux ans et déjà c'était en
partie d'un discussions trois heures
dans good 3h amusé j'avais le malheur de
lui dire quelque chose à musique laisse
moi parler sous ces trois heures qu'elle
parlait donc six minutes je le fais mort
les yeux les yeux c'était une anecdote
avec sans ponctuation
c'est mal raconté ses brouillons mais
c'est jean-michel on a quand même oui
quand je rentrais chez moi j'étais en
couple et je retrouvais ma meuf
comment travaille avec des patous
surnommé il est doté à tout ça ne fait
ce n'est pas la seule à la règle était
que du nord il aime tous bernard donc
connaître me touche à tous les desserts
allez c'est reparti on reprend je vous
fais avec donne car moi je ne suis pas
je ne dis pas n'importe quoi
sachez d'abord que j'ai eus vingt-et-une
conquêtes féminines dans ma vie après ce
vote est une conquête une ratée indoor
une avec qui je suis resté un an et demi
oui comment jean bernard non à sable et
céline céline elle magnifie alleo vers
des magasins non à les marier maintenant
elle a des enfants et où elle a été très
malheureuse dame en développement
pensent qu'elle est encore quand je
rentrais le soir effectivement ce
qu'elle raconte est parfois c'était
intéressant et pourtant je me faisais
chier et pourquoi
et bien un petit peu de sociologie
propos du tout parce qu'en fait et on le
voit avec mamie ou parfois benhaim c'est
un problème de rythme ma femme ne savent
pas raconté dans son arrêté mettre les
fans de salaire à monter jean-michel
n'est pas une femme sait pas combien ils
perdront tout regarder même si ça n'a
pas d'intérêt vont rythmer je suis une
femme je voulais j'avais dit on peut pas
faire
et agathe rappelle qu'on parle de ce
sondage les hommes sont incapable
d'écouter une femme plus de six minutes
ce serait intéressant de faire ce
sondage sur 2000 femmes parce que je
pense pas que les hommes soient plus
intéressant que nous mais je suis assez
d'accord alors les thématiques alors les
thématiques les tops le top des sujets
qui n'intéressent pas les sommes qu'on
leur ferme pas en huitième position
quand elle parle des personnes qu'elle
n'a jamais fait qu'il n'a jamais
rencontré du genre par la fin j'étais
avec jf de la coupe la vie il a pété aux
écoutes c'est bien simple on était dans
le bureau il dit ouais t'as pas une
performeuse judy non il a il pète un
captage à mais rien pour moi ouais ça
veut dire quoi
de fil en aiguille sémillon rtt ça fait
deux jours qu'il n'est pas venu à la
compta c'est le bordel personne n'a été
payée figure toi que martine elle même
est bien ici mais au congé parental
donc martine je veux te dire on la voit
plus pendant deux mois tu m'as cas si
les yatchs tu as raison tu es une femme
[Applaudissements]
alors en fait ça c'est les personnes qui
allaient me regret et quand la femme
parle aussi de ses collègues de boulot
les pipoles peut-être pas là ouais mais
aussi pour moi j'aime bien cette semaine
la mode et le shopping
moi j'adore alors le top des sujets qui
n'intéressent pas les hommes donc
quatrième position les relations
sentimentales d'autres gens que le mari
ne connaît pas à bâle
oui combien vous êtes une femme en fait
non mais vous connaissez cette phase 6
minutes si on n'a pas couché avec ce n'a
pas couché avec on pouvait coûter trois
quarts d'heure une heure deux heures
sans fond de coucher avec ses six
minutes avant de coucher avec moi c'est
ma vie de woods et futuna c'est l'offre
excéderait tous tant qu'on n'a pas coulé
elle va coucher ça prend six minutes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quarante écoute par intérêt toi d'après
lui les chauffeurs-livreurs cantiran
club la livrée des aubergines et des
oranges tout là jamais je peux te dire à
hilla et les haïtiens est fatigué a
plein de mecs n'ont pas tous connu ça
quand tu dragues nana et raconte des
trucs ça ni queue ni tête et dacia c'est
super aujourd'hui argent me jean me jean
mis 6 mois d'armée j'écoute les femmes
tout le temps moi à oui mais non je suis
je assez attentif à ce qu'elles
attentionné vous même après l'amour
accorde une attention ne me l'a pas tous
en même temps a donc un truc intéressé
je rigolais la 10è qui est intéressé aux
femmes
mais même après l'amour non ah oui mais
sans rire je peux dire il a un truc est
très mignon jean-michel quand il couche
avec une personne qui ne connaît pas
lorsqu'il est dans la rue
chez toi un peu journée s'il a fait
venir oui mais à une personne qui est
très mignon c'est que quand c'est
terminé et badr est un x 3 4 heures
après ils discutent offrir un verre moi
quand c'est terminé c'est 7 à 3 minutes
pour tomber alors lui je vous dirais
qu'il a dit là il a une application
fumeurs qui relie à sakété peur comme et
ça c'est un truc de bon alors c'est quoi
on top 3 ce qui a été fait ou dit sur
les réseaux sociaux ça n'intéresse pas
du tout les autres de l'horoscope de sa
femme et est ce qui intéresse le moins
les hommes dans une conversation avec
une femme
c'est ce que sa femme a mangé le midi ça
c'est pas gentil ça m'intéresse ça vous
intéresse ça bien sûr il a mangé quoi
vous semez dit j'ai pas dessiner bonjour
j'ai quoi ce mini jeux moisis du tout et
des légumes je m'en fous tôt cette voie
là j'ai mangé quoi des oeufs alors pour
savoir elle mange des jeux tous les
allemands non mais on vous adore mais
elle mange avec ses doigts mon frère
alors on va passer du coq à l'âne
les frères elle tu vas manger une fois
avec elle mon frère mais écoute moi bien
tu veux faire un régime
je mange avec l frère écoute moi bien
elle prend la maillot comme ça ça veut
dire c'est un tour de magie saônoise
idéal
ah non mais elle mon père que c'est un
phénomène
elle est phénoménale mais écoute moi
bien elle prend les houches desu comme
ça les pros commence à faire a minima
comme un salut à dieulefit si un jour
j'ai moi j'avais quelque part elle avait
une porte ici
[Applaudissements]
abdou el hammadia camille manger un
poisson elle avait même dû tout duquel
ils vont mais parce que j'ai bouffé min
non non je m'en fais des bonnes femmes
accus
[Rires]